it's growing steadily um the market is
and when I'm saying that it from very
very different angles one because a
secondary transaction is more
appropriate for bigger companies because
like I said you're doing get unlimited
information and you're getting shares
that are inferior in terms of Rights and
it's a better it's a it's a financial
transaction by its nature it's not a VC
transaction um and therefore it's better
fit for bigger and larger
companies and you know luckily during
the last decade uh if when we started
out there were 37 unicorns in the world
worldwide okay which are you know these
These are the prospects that are fitting
for a secondary
[Music]
transaction hi Chief welcome H to the
Maas experiment and 20- minute leaders
I'm really excited to have you here um
as I always do with these episodes I I
treat them as experiments and I treat
the experiment as a hypothesis
validation and and then some evidence
I'm really excited to dive into another
hypothesis today today we're all about
secondary markets we're talking about
the world in which we're all living in
especially in startup nation and and of
course the whole Tech ecosystem and also
a subject I know very little about so
I'm really excited to understand it
better from you K you're the CEO of the
elephant you're a very an extremely
significant player in this ecosystem so
obviously an extremely relevant
conversation to have with you as an
expert and and I'm just excited for for
the next H for the next conversation so
Kim again welcome thank you Mel it's a
pleasure uh being here and thanks for
having me um I think we're going to have
a short um intro on what you know
secondary means for those of us who are
not familiar with it I think that people
in in in you know in the tech ecosystem
are more familiar with what we call
primary where a company raises money uh
with from investors go through thee
diligence process and you know sign the
documentation and they receive money
into the company and they issue new
shares usually we're talking about
different classes of shares as the
company moves forward so they start with
seed and preed actually and then they go
through rounds a b c d and issue new
class of shares every round um when
we're talking and and and the company is
the one that benefits from the funding
okay they raise money for the uh for the
company to allow it to to grow and
expand and and move forward um but what
has happened you know along the the past
I guess 15 years is that private
companies have been acre enormous value
and keep on staying private they're not
going public if if the statistics were
three to five years for companies to to
go public or or disappear unfortunately
but you know you had you had a a you
know a term that you you could expect
the company to understand if you have an
exit or not now companies are staying
private for 10 12 15 years and they're
still very successful and they're
creating enormous value you know we just
saw that uh SpaceX did a secondary
tender basically at a valuation of $200
billion doar and they're still private
okay um so this is a phenomenon that
that that has come about the past 15
years and you're seeing a lot more
private companies huge private companies
that are taking their time with going
public um what that means is that you
have
shareholders employees Founders early
investors who invested in the company or
received options in the company and
they're sitting on enormous value of
shares but it's still private so you
know I'll give you just you know a great
example of a a deal we just did for a an
ex employee of a startup that is valued
now at $1 13
billion and his salary was under
$100,000 a year and his shares were
worth $15
million so and and he's moved on from
this company and now he's you know in a
startup of his own and he needs you know
a couple million dollars to support it
and he's says listen I'm sitting on this
piece of paper it's worth a lot of money
and you know how do I how do I actually
get liquidity how do I actually monetize
this piece of paper and so that's an
example of you know and then and this is
obviously a worldwide phenomenon where
we seeing more and more private
companies worth a lot more money and
staying private for longer so there's a
need for liquidity uh and that need for
liquidity is just growing as um you know
these companies are are creating more
value so that's you know from from from
the sales side from the other side you
have investors who want to come into
these companies but when the companies
are doing what we said a primary round
as we explained where they are raising
funds these are already big companies
they only talk to the big boys right
they'll talk to andreon harwitz and
they'll talk to Black Rock and they'll
talk to you know the the people they
don't just come and check write a $50
million check they're also familiar
names and they can take them further and
whatever so even if you come with $10
million check they're not going to take
you so if I want to invest now in
anthropic if I want to invest now in you
know the big names you don't have access
um in the primary so now we have an
option three connecting these sellers
and these buyers and this this is a
secondary transaction so a secondary
transaction is where you're buying
shares from an existing shareholder he
gets
liquidity uh and and uh he exercises
some of his Holdings and you step into
his shoes as an investor in the company
so that is you know the basic difference
between secondaries and primaries um and
this is where we've realized and we've
been doing this for for a long time
there this need is only going to grow um
like we said companies are staying
private for longer more and more uh
value is is is locked and needs to be
unlocked and need to be freed up uh and
this is this is the solutions that we
that we come to uh to to bring I I have
a question so I mean what you're saying
effectively first of all it makes a lot
of sense you're basically saying
something very you know you you you
mentioned the market Trend that says
this until until recently or until or in
previously the ability for us to be
primary shareholders of companies was
made through the fact that companies
reached public had a public offering
within three to five years and so the
span at which you were not able to do
that was pretty small and and so we were
able to do that but now given that
companies are extending their lifespan
of of them being in a private situation
extending now to 10 plus years and we
see that and you mentioned for example
SpaceX and and we have many many many
examples now then there there's now a
new Need for for two types of sh
stakeholders one is you have the
stakeholders that want to sell right
they have there were perhaps X employees
or Founders or they have they have some
shares within the organization and they
want to sell and then you have the other
uh stakeholders who want to buy and they
are the ones who don't have access
necessarily to the deal as primary
shareholders but they want to have
access as investors so that they can
continue and and expand on the value
that they're generating and so this
enter this is what you classify as the
secondary Market
now hopefully I got that roughly correct
but what is a what is really this the
challenge here so why what are the
market dynamics that make this non not
trivial as in hey K I saw you invested
in this company can I just buy a few
shares from you because I like it right
well first of all what we explained was
the most basic part of the secondary
Market there's a lot more variations to
it but you know we we we'll try to keep
it simple and and and yes you've you've
you've touched on you know some
challenges that we face in transacting
uh in the secondaries market and it
starts with the first first of all it's
a private company it's not a publicly
traded company that you can just go
online enter your your your brokerage
account and buy shares of a public
company and sell shares Etc um these are
private companies and and and and it has
to be approved by the company you have
to go through the process of the company
which includes right of first refusal
right of first offer whatever is is is
in their uh governing documents articles
of Association you have to go through
kyc and transfer of funds and if we're
talking about employees you have to
build bring in the um you know the ESOP
trustee and and it's it's a long process
it it takes time but the first thing is
does the Company allow a secondary
transaction and you know the company on
one hand may want to give liquidity and
it serves their purposes in one way but
at the same time it also uh gets in the
way of maybe other things that the
company has in mind maybe they don't
want the employees to have too much
liquidity and then you know they become
rich and they leave the company the next
day so you know that's something they
have to take maybe they're doing a
primary Round And if a secondary
transaction is usually done at a
discount because these are usually
common shares or early referred shares
and whereas the valuation of the company
was set for the last uh primary round of
whatever class of of preferred shares
but it's it's it's later on so usually
it involves a discount to to mitigate on
that maybe the company doesn't want
while they're trying to raise to see
their shares being traded at a 30%
discount 40% discount whatever it is um
so I'm saying that there are some
interests that are not necessarily
aligned and some
excuse me sometimes it also depends on
where the company's at at that point in
time if they're doing a primary round
maybe they'll halt it maybe now they
want to give more liquidity so they'll
be they'll be more Cooperative so there
the idea is that at the end of the day
you're dependent on the company's um you
know cooperation not just in the
technical side of things of processing a
transaction okay and going through the
right of first refusal and the
registration and whatever you also need
almost in every company you need board
approval for a secondary transaction and
that's that's already where you get into
uh you know sometimes conflictive
interests um you know of the
companies and another
um another I guess Gap that you need to
to to bridge in order to get a a deal
done is information Gap okay when you're
doing a primary transaction and you're
working with a company you have all the
data in front of you all right you have
your lawyers doing due diligence you
have your accountants doing due
diligence you have your patent lawyers
doing due diligence and you you know the
company pretty much inside out and where
they're at where there is a secondary
transaction and the company is not the
one receiving the funds okay or it's not
a company Le secondary tender okay the
interest of the company to um to reveal
and basically to hand over their their
data
um is limited and therefore they
sometimes will not uh allow the
transaction at all sometimes they will
allow it but they will not provide any
data sometimes they will provide you
know a certain level of data subject to
NDA and whatever so that is also a gap
that you need to bridge between uh
sometimes even the seller doesn't have
the data and sometimes even if he has
the data he can't share it because he's
under
confidentiality right but you as an
investor it's great that you read in the
newspaper a great article about the
company but if you want to know exactly
what's going on there or at least to a
an extent that you feel comfortable with
doing a transaction based on certain
Financial parameters you need that data
so that is also a challenge that
sometimes can be uh you know difficult
for for the parties to uh to to get to
Common Grounds so I I I'm really curious
you know you you're spent you've spent
the last more than eight years that with
the elephant and you're obviously very
interested in the space what what gets
you really excited about about this
ecosystem and and what you get to do so
what what is it about this this space
and the secondary Market that that makes
you very curious and and interested
here um first of all it's it's growing
steadily um the market is and when I'm
saying that it from very very different
angles
one because a secondary transaction is
more appropriate for bigger companies
because like I said you're doing get
unlimited information and you're getting
shares that are inferior in terms of
Rights and it's a better it's a it's a
financial transaction by its nature it's
not a VC transaction um and therefore
it's better fit for bigger and larger
companies and you know luckily during
the last decade uh if when we started
out there were 37 unicorns in the world
worldwide okay which are you know these
These are the prospects that are fitting
for a secondary transaction um now we're
talking about over 1,200 1300 you know
whatever depends how you want to count
it worldwide so now if you want to do a
if for example you want to do a a a
secondary transaction in a cyber
security company it's not oh I got one
let's you know try and get what you you
got you know a list of names that you
can pick from and try to choose the that
that is that you know you believe in and
and whatever the the value that's been
uh created and locked has grown
exponentious over the past decade um and
that's why this secondary Market is
growing to over hundred billion dollars
a year in terms of transaction Val
volume is because the need is growing
and what's also exciting to see is the
um tools that are growing in parallel to
uh uh you know to the market if it's
plat data platforms that you can now you
know find out information on the company
without the company telling you right
because you have like um you know
platforms like pitchbook and crunch base
and whatever and you can find out
whatever and it helps to to complete the
picture um whether it's you know NASDAQ
already also building the secondary
Market uh uh platform that we work with
and you know that brings legitimacy into
the process and again and you're seeing
that the the public market is shrinking
and the private Market is growing so you
understand where is the direction of the
value where it stands the breakdown
between public and and private and the
more sophisticated that the you know the
secondary Market is going to become and
like we said through data platforms and
trading platforms and uh um secondary
platforms like ourselves
the better tools you're going to have
and the better process that you're going
to be able to create to make it smoother
it's only going to make you know
complete the picture and the shift I
think from you know public markets to to
the private it's not going to replace it
okay let's you know we're not fooling
ourselves but there's plenty of room
from from between but if I look at you
know where you see where what is growing
and what is actually declining and
you're seeing the the focus moving you
know to private markets that that really
gets me excited because I understand
that what we saw about a decade ago uh
is is is happening and maturing in front
of our eyes uh and we're we're really
looking forward to to you know see where
the future is is holding on that love it
K this is a this is very cool and it
sounds I mean it just sounds like we're
we're everything is evolving and
everything is growing and uh and we're
identifying the right mechanisms to
create win-win situations here and and I
love going back to how you started to to
explaining how you have the different
parties who have different who who are
looking to to to play the same game and
and they have different reasons but but
but ultimately it's all about creating
the right platform that enables them to
have that win-win Synergy and um and
which I think is just um very exciting
in general I mean it's and especially
1,00 1300 unicorns in comparison to to H
dozens or hundreds before and uh and so
it's it's very very exciting and I
really want to thank you for coming here
and and sharing this time with me and
your your insights and and uh continuing
to to do great work with the
elephant and thank you very much K thank
you m thanks for having me have a great
I really appreciate it